trump yesterday for president's day just
got out to spend some time with uh
people here in uh in
mar-a-lago he drove around and people
were going crazy here and
but that's because it's him he was out
there they're not out there just i get
that okay
what i what i'm what i'm saying with
this is you know what i'm saying with
this is
trump okay so my message isn't directed
to mega people
it's not my message isn't even directed
to trump
my message is you had a candidate like
trump he pushed the envelope
yes the twitter stuff out of control
should have been controlled look at
biden it's so quiet nothing's going on
like that's
you said something you said it's so much
peace or climate today right okay
but the mega crowd had somebody to buy
into
okay what did trump do trump went and
converted people
trump converted people you have to know
that trump is a converter in 2016 he did
of course in twenty not in 2020
trump is one of the greatest converters
america's ever seen are you kidding me
like day one like trump's gonna run
out of the 16 people who's at the top
he's at the bottom jeb bush was at the
top 140 million dollars
even huckabee was ahead of trump carson
was ahead of trump
anybody that can get you to vote for
obama twice and then vote for trump
you're converting
you you're you're a converter you're a
converter
however however they realized
that they didn't have the right allies
and number two they realized the
republican party
didn't have the right tools like the
left does
the left controls all the tools they
didn't have all the tools this isn't
about that the mega crowd is going to go
away
50 years from now we're going to watch a
movie if we're still alive i'm going to
be 92 we'll still be alive because 50
years from now we're still going to be
alive apparently we're going to let's go
1 10. so we'll be here so 50 20 years
from now
30 years from when we go to movies and
we watch the movie of what happened the
last four five six years with trump
you're gonna be like i cannot believe i
lived through that that's what you're
gonna say yeah i cannot
live through that totally but he is
still going
to have loyal followers 10
20 30 40 years from now this is not
going away
if i sat down with trump and i did an
interview it'd be a very different kind
of an interview
very very different kind of an interview
very it'd be a very different kind of an
interview because
i you know my opinion he's at a point
right now
that's a very challenging place to be
okay
because look when you do case studies
what's the benefit of reading case
studies when you go to mba school what
is the only benefit of going to mba
making those mistakes yeah do you you
learn from other companies when you look
at case studies
what is the best case study that trump
should study what is the best case study
that trump should look at
what's the best case study what what
what family
kennedy kennedy okay kennedy what is the
case study of kennedy's family
well you got the the joe the guy that
started it all
right who was in politics raising kids
to follow him and
okay you know change the country yeah
telling his kids hey one of you guys
going to grow up and be a president
which ones are going to be
wear a suit at dinner look sha he's
mentally getting his kids to be prepared
to be a president right and essentially
they were supposed to be presidents for
16 years
then the kids would have been president
that's the direction it was going
so then what happened who became the
sacrificial guy
well jfk got assassinated what happened
to the entire kennedy family
so so to trump right now if he wants if
he's a true believer and comes back and
you know says i'm going to come back in
2024 and does what he says he wants to
do if he does that
the same thing that happened to
kennedy's family could potentially
happen to the trump family
okay they're going to go after his
businesses they're going to have he's
going to be in court
between now and 2024. he got acquitted
which means he can run again in 2023.
jack dorsey said i don't care what
happens i'm not letting him back on
twitter no matter what happens right so
he's still going to have a different
platform to be able to
post stuff on you're not going to go in
parlor and be able to do much because
partner is going to be all on one side
you need
neutral platforms to convert because
trump is
the ultimate converter agree or disagree
trump's a master converter the guy went
from being who he was to being a
billionaire to being on tv to being all
that stuff to being a president you said
wait you became a tv guy yes what
you you you and from your dad was doing
rentals on the other side
you want to become yeah the trump team
is everywhere yeah you wrote books ball
wall street bestseller no
yes you became a president yes you got
what are you talking
so he's at a point right now that do i
just lay low to make sure my family can
at least
have a peaceful life moving forward or
do i say screwed guys
we may have a target from us from some
of the most powerful people in the world
that
more more powerful than us but let's go
save this country it's going to be
interesting
but the mega audience is not going away
here's why i disagree with your
discipline
i'd love to hear it because uh trump is
a cult of personality that's what he is
he's got that charisma where people
would just follow him if he
decides i'm not going back into politics
it's not worth it
these people the mega followers are
going to feel betrayed
they're going to take it very personally
and they're not there is no more mega
then because they were there to follow
trump and if he bails on them
they'll bail too and you look at the
people that have been arrested
you know that uh stormed the capitol
right and remember
we were on the air the next day that
happened on a wednesday we did the
podcast on a thursday and i said that
day i guarantee you
you know they got about two weeks half
these people that got arrested are gonna
ask to get pardoned
right and a lot of them did but you know
you listen to them now and they all are
saying
i thought i was being led to do this i
thought he was telling us i mean i think
a lot of them feel betrayed
like he's stepped away percentage though
what percentage
i mean what percentage of the 74 million
felt but okay
so first of all you know the 74 million
people that voted what percentage voted
because they didn't vote for trump they
voted republican
what would you say you know i'm gonna
say a lot a big percentage okay
because i mean that would be me i mean i
was voting for the lower taxes and all
those things
so what percentage of the 74 million
voted republican not voted mega
okay i'm going to say you know 48 50 55
percent because i think a lot of the
women the suburban women that don't like
trump would still vote
can you pull up the the record of how
many people
uh vote republicans every election like
how many total votes what would you say
adam
how many just vote republican regardless
paul what do you think what percentage
of the 74 million people that voted
voted republican not voted trump they
voted policies not for trump
80 okay so i i i uh uh
uh meaning their report they're voting
republican regardless they're voting for
his policies but they're saying
this guy's a little bit out of control
on twitter but i have to vote for his
policies still voting reports okay
so 80 i think so so then that means that
at the 74 million the 100
diehard mega believers are what say 20
what's 20 of 74 million 15 million out
of 15 million people how many of them do
you believe
are like dude you forced me to go to
capital that's what you did what
percentage of the 15 million you think
less than one percent that's what i'm
saying i don't think that's the case i
think the case is
that uh it's not 74 million
mega i think it's 15 million meg i think
it's very important to differentiate
between those two
you understand what i'm saying it's not
so so it's not like if
if we break down the math are you mega
like did you are you like die hard mega
no
okay but you're republican you voted
that that way okay so
but you're not like going around saying
you know even though you said 33
a few podcasts ago so to me it's
principles it's mega
and then you know so i think it's a 20
market and i don't think that 15 million
is going away i i don't think that 15
million is going to go
well okay if you look i don't think mega
is going anywhere no i don't think it's
going away and i don't think trump is
going anywhere either
i think he's such a do you think he runs
2024 oh yeah i do
you think he wants 2024 i do not i do
not think he's going to run such an
egomaniac
is he going to run 2024
okay i i actually do you know i think
he's coming back i think it's going to
be an ugly situation
trump if we've learned anything from
trump he's not the type of person to be
like
well guys we had a good shot thanks
everybody the day of the insurrection
the day that they were trying to hang
mike pence he was not
calling in the military he did nothing
to stop that
nothing so if we've learned anything
from trump he ain't backing down from
anything he's going to double triple
quadruple down
there's one there's one thing i don't
want to see i don't want to see on the
debate stage
trump and pence i don't think that's
good for me i would love to see that
yeah i don't either and here's the other
thing if trump runs again he destroys
all his businesses and the legacy he
built with the brand
i i think it's done and his kids are in
serious danger too if he runs again and
i think he'll put his family above it
why would he be in serious danger if he
ran well the the the brand is already
extremely tarnished
if he gets in again it'll be dissolved i
mean there's no one with i mean
outside that fringe element but how
about this he built it here's a bigger
question
i think he's going to run again in 2024
straight up does he run does he have
them i think he's running republican
maga not independent no
that's my opinion does he have a shot
in 2024 if he's going against a a joe
biden
even a kamala or even a uh i mean a lot
of that
it's so early to even tell because it's
just he's just been president for one
month biden so we don't know how
things are gonna if it opens up say say
things open up
and market go dow goes to 40. okay if
dow goes to 40
market opens up biden biden's able to
influence powell
to go one more year at zero percent
interest rate and we have this fake
economy
and he gets real i mean it's going to be
tough to it's
you know most people want to vote for
the same president most people don't
want to historically we like two terms
we don't like one terms right
okay so you have to you have to keep
that part of mind as well you're gonna
do pretty damn bad if you're gonna
only go one term or it has to be a
massive crisis
like a kobet coming in with a world
shuts down or
a third-party candidate like ross
perrault in 92. hurts george bush you're
right so there has to be a
you know a black what do they call it a
uh what's the
black swan it has to be some and this
covet is a black swan like
if there's no covid what's the
percentage of trump it's real
yeah i mean so you have to realize kobe
kind of threw him out so
i think if there's not if the dow's at
40 he extends the interest rates for one
more percent
one more year and it's pretty peaceful
things have opened up restaurants
everybody's up they're gonna
okay let's just go one more year yeah a
long way to go one month out of what 48.
exactly yeah we got something to your
point
you brought up the uh the situation
where
uh the overall sentiment of the country
feels a little more mellow now a lot
less stressed
you know i threw it out there given the
given the situation at hand
i threw it out there as a question does
does there seem to be less tension
less stress does the country seem to be
a little less on edge and i'm just gonna
say yeah i mean i
i feel it for real in california um it
does feel different
and i don't think it's a rally behind
biden and it certainly has nothing to do
with newsome you know our governor
hopefully we get out here in a few
months i think it's the byproduct of
this there's less
bickering every day this insane thing
that we were going through for months
and months i think it feels differently
walking around i think um you know if
there was any political motivation
behind the shutdowns of what was going
on they're easing up a little bit like
where i live the
restaurants are open again down or
outside i mean those these little
freedoms you take
you know that you used to take for
granted are now a huge deal to be able
to go sit somewhere
go to a gym these are huge things and i
do think that
the collective mood of the country is
better over the last month
i think i agree i just think the the
word that comes to mind when i think of
trump in the last four years
and it served him well in some cases and
it served him not well in other cases
is frenzy it was always a friend the
news of the day
and trump tweeted this and here's who
he's fighting with and here's what he
said about this
and trump did this it's just so frenzied
and
you know every day i mean he would
always you know
control the media control the narrative
friends and friends like
i'm good with sleepy joe just kind of
keeping it cool and just
go be sleepy joe we've had a very
frenzied four years
just get back to basics just do the work
it doesn't need to be a
rock star you don't need to be uh you
know a
personality just freaking makes politics
work it's so weird how we are as voters
you know we go from on obama oh he's a
socialist he's this to we go to a trump
oh he's so you know he's always non-stop
talking like can't you just be quiet we
go to a guy that never wants to come out
and he's just quiet
yeah we are so radical sometimes let me
let
me hear let me say something and this is
that i i recognize this yeah i say this
every time that they talk about politics
this is if you want to know politics in
this country
it's a pendulum we're all the way here
it's like an oval
no not an oval it's like a half circle
marriage is like an oval
where's that movie what movie is that uh
harry and uh what is uh
adam no no it's the adam sandler movie i
now pronounce you doug and larry yeah
duggan or something like that yeah it's
like an old chuck and larry chuck and
larry chuck and larry is what it is
whatever what a pendulum think about it
you know even the last 20 years
you go from reagan yeah right all the
way to the right or conservative you
know bush
four years boom clinton clinton eight
years
boom right after that pendulum go back
to bush from bush you go to obama
yeah but you know what this is like just
keep going i don't think that's it i'll
give you a different analogy if you want
to do analogies i'll give you
this is like the guy that's like listen
man this last girl i dated
i i just want somebody that's a little
bit calmer
i want her to be calm like this is too
much like she's like yeah and they go
day to come dude i'm so bored
outside you know once again and they're
like and then i watched cocktails the
other day
and he's telling the uh uh what do you
call it the the you know
his uh buddy coughlin's law the guy
whoever that guy is
yeah he says uh he says you know you you
can never land a billionaire you can't
he he's teasing him so he goes and gets
the billionaire the girl in the corner
yeah so he's going to her place
and one of the days he wakes up and
she's like ah and two
and three and he said and he says every
day at five o'clock in the morning like
he's like dude
you wanted the girl now you got it so i
just want a family girl
so america can't make up we're going to
be tyler we're bipolar
it's an understatement you know over the
last month i've literally
you know for vt post i'm going there
seems to be better stories to cover
better stories to choose and i'm going
why is that
have more interesting people just come
to the forefront but but here's what it
is
trump is such an oxygen suck you know he
absorbs
everything from both sides both sides
are obsessed with him the left side
hates him so much
that's all they can do is talk about him
and react to him same thing with the
right he dominates
everything every news cycle hollywood
changed because of him
every industry essentially changed
because of the feeling he just sucks all
the energy out of a room
right now there's other things to talk
about you're hearing more about some
business stories and they entertain i
think hollywood might go back to being a
little bit more hollywood i used the
analogy of watching jimmy fallon last
night it felt like a different show
compared to what he aired the last two
years so it's i think it
that he is such uh and you know just an
outlier
as far as the personality of him and
what he brings to the table i think it's
better for the country
if he probably just says i had my run
and i'm good well other other stories
are getting some data by the way if you
think again we may have a different
crowd because
they're going crazy right now i'm
furious with you guys if you think he's
gonna run again
put thumbs up if you think there's no
way in the world he's gonna run in 2024
push thumbs down so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye